we extended our best wishes and I was he  was a very fine man I met him on  numerous occasions he was just a high  quality man who truly loves his family  one thing that came through loud and  clear is very proud of his family and  very much loved Estonian so he's  terrific guy he'll be missed in a letter  full life and very alluring life we've  decided as you know we're going to have  a big press conference today which I  actually look forward to because we've  made tremendous progress at the g20 with  many nations and we were going to have a  very big press conference and out of  respect for President Bush we've  canceled it here and we'll have it back  in Washington at some time in the near  future sometimes after the funeral  service